♪ ♪ ♪- Munich, Allemagne,
le 5 septembre,
les Jeux olympiques, symbole
de la Fraternité internationale,
PHILIPPE SAINT-CYR,
arbitre en haltérophilie
- Il y a eu des terroristes
qui onleleleleleleleleleleleleë.
- Pour l'arbitre
en haltérophilie Philippe
Saint-Cyr, ce sont ses premiers
voyage en Europe. Un rêve qui va
se transformer en cauchemar.
- Ils ont pris des otages.
Ils nous ont dit qu'il y avait
probablement des morts.
- Pierre Dufault faisait partie
de l'équipe de Radio-C
couvrait les Jeux olympiques.
PHILIPPE SAINT-CYR
arbitre en haltérophilie
- Et il y a eu dt t t t t t t t,
puis ils s'entendaient pas.
- Finalement, on sait
qu'ils vont partir à l'aéroport
militairurururururururururururu.
- Le 5 septembre 1972,
Charles Biétry est journaliste
à l'Agence France-Presse.
- On part àororororort.
Et d'un seul coup,
j'entends, moi...
(détonations)
... des coups de feu.
une gerbe bleue dans le ciel.
Je saurai après que c'est
l'hélicoptère quilelelelelelele.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Je suis très content
car, autant que je le sache,
cette opération de police
- Tout à coup, il nous arrive
une dépêche : la radio allemande
vient d'annoncer qu'il y a eu
solution, il y a p p p p p p p ,
tout est fini, tout est beau,
tout est parfait. On leur dit :
CHARLES BIÉTRY,
ououououournaliste, AFP
- Moi j'ai entendu des coups
de feu. Moi, j'ai vu cette gerbt
une explosion, je sais pas
de quoi, mais... ils peuvent pas
dire qu'il s'est rien passé
et que tout va bien.
♪ ♪ ♪
Et puis, à un moment, j'arrive
devant une petite porte.
Quand elle s'ouvre, il sort
un Msosososososososososososososs
qui coulent là.
Excusez-moi. J'ai toujours
un peu de mal sur, e
sur ce moment-là.
demande : "qui êtes-vous?"
Et il réWaWaWaWaWalther Tröger,
le maire de Munich." Je dis :
"qu'est-ce qui s'est passé?"
Et il me répond : "Sie sind
alle tot", ils sont tous morts.
"Vir hab
on va tout rater.
C'est... stupéfaction totale
de nous dire que tout s'était
bien passé.
Donc, je viens de savoir
l'opération de libération
la police allemande,
eh bien, ça n'rcrcrcrcrché,
et c'est épouvantable
ce qui vient de passer.
des athlètes israéliens
des Jeux olympiques.
sont morts.
t t t t t cet ancien journaliste
de l'AFP qui va annoncer
la dramatique nouvelle
- Le lendemain matin,
on se lève, croyant que tout
revient à la normale et c'est là
Ils sont tous morts.
- Les autorités allemandestttttt
11 otages. 2 ont été tuésnsnsns,
9 ont été tués à l'aéroport
ce soir. Ils sont tous morts
Ici Robert Frosi,
Radio-Canada, Montréa